what's up with your boy KFC from
barstool sports for the last seven years
we've been doing our podcast KFC radio
answering the weirdest questions the
Internet has to offer
and now we're putting celebrities and
comedians to the test this is answer the
internet today's episode is brought to
you by post mates anything you want
anytime you want it postmates it
download the post mates app use promo
code KFC for $100 off your delivery
charge for the next seven days
that's promo code KFC for $100 off
delivery charge for the next seven days
hey it's JB Smoove this is answer the
internet
give me that damn thing if you could
party with one sports team in history
who would it be party with one sports
team it'll probably be the old time the
old time the old Jets that wanted to
vote yeah hey my man Joe Namath Joe
Willie you really had ladies yeah girls
on the sideline he had he had drinks on
the sideline little cocktail table on
the sideline and a man wore a coat on
the damn sideline who did it better than
Joe Willie huh NYC all damn day and then
we're party on the sideline but win the
game from a party after the game to
that's how Joe really did it who wins in
a street fight allen iverson or Yamin
come on man
first of all Allen Iverson had to cross
over we seen him cross over Jordan you
mean he's on me he couldn't cross up
y'all means big-ass goofy ass feet and
he had two badass feet most time guys
had one bad foot yeah I had two [ __ ]
up ass feet he [ __ ] up so what
happened at st. was born with a right on
his left and the left one is right so
both feet went out like this that's why
I speak up [ __ ] up on him all the
time hey I custom-made shoes and [ __ ]
who would you rather be a clown or a
magician and do the same [ __ ] day huh
huh if you do magic you're a [ __ ]
clown
what professional athlete would you
choose to be your college roommate oh
man let me see professional athlete I
would choose somebody like my like like
like like a running back oh my good
running back sometime you want something
go on a coffee run or some [ __ ] like
that you need somebody who's able to go
[ __ ] coffee and bring the air
straight the [ __ ] back quarterbacks
don't know how to come back you want to
run him back like a Tony Dorsett or
somebody like an iconic running back or
maybe a Earl Campbell a [ __ ] who
cannot people out the [ __ ] out the way
you [ __ ] my way I'm coming to knock you
on your ass this hot-ass coffee just
cool off if you enter a beauty pageant
what would your talent be oh I was going
I got damn thing to do the [ __ ]
running man the [ __ ] I would do right
I'll do the [ __ ] run him in like this
but I will do this [ __ ] in the [ __ ]
baby super see that put the heels on the
baby suit on and [ __ ] titties bouncing
this [ __ ] a pig a pig's orgasm lasts for
over 30 minutes a lion can have sex over
50 times per a day which would you
rather be oh [ __ ] man nah [ __ ] that I
would rather do the sex 50 times a day
all right you cabbage that [ __ ] out
that's like the times a day that's
approximately thirty two thousand four
hundred and seventy five strokes yes if
you could be a ghost and haunt one
person who would you haunt oh [ __ ]
who the [ __ ] without haunt I would
probably go and and be a ghost
I won't what one person our haunt people
like I would like be a ghost and a
[ __ ] target some [ __ ] like that
there's something stupid I started bring
something back I'm a hot the [ __ ] out of
you the world even loses all women or
all sports which you choose ladies you
go
you are building your dick from scratch
and can make it as big as you want but
for every inch you add you'll lose two
years off your life how big do you make
it oh man on average so you you you want
to be able to still have you don't see
you [ __ ] lose you win and lose with
this [ __ ] you got custom-made pants on
but you got a [ __ ] around I wear
pajamas all the [ __ ] time
god dammit man what the [ __ ] do you do
all you have your pants made is you can
have an extra extra leg built into your
[ __ ] pants so now see you said big
units you say so big so for every inch
you add now is that width or that
[ __ ] length that's my [ __ ]
question they did who would you rather
be the best-looking dudes in the world
I'll be able to read six minds god damn
these kind of things kind of work
together [ __ ] but nobody wanna [ __ ]
good-looking dude with a [ __ ] mute
I'll tell you that much that [ __ ] don't
work hmm
you want to do is be able to speak and
put game on ladies and [ __ ] like that
reading the [ __ ] mind nah the last
thing you want to read a chick's mind
and she's saying and her brain I was
just ugly [ __ ] get out my face
so you wonder looks all the [ __ ] time
looks
[Laughter]
you